[Musique]
et bien croyez vous qu'il y ait de papus
ne faut trop d'écho beauté bien sûr
photo award
attention il en manque un
pourquoi il est beau mais qu'il est faux
moi je vends que je suis beau mais nos
petits sauts mongolienne regard des mots
prend que moi pour quoi faire
bonjour aux billes tu es fou pâte et zut
un bijou de cette valeur et alors ça
fera doubler de valeur
on joue pas vicat bijoux j'aimerais bien
avoir un collier comme ça
la colo est face à moi c'est plus joli
là il m'apprend
elle constitue pour aller avec mon
collier le rouge ou le bleu le bleu
comme tu n'as pas très bon goût je
mettrai le rouge
des fois où je regrette de n'être pas
vraiment méchante que fais tu es avec ce
rouleau à pâtisserie vous chassent les
mouches les mouches
quelle mouche elles ne sont plus là
puisque vous les échasses et cher
patator non seulement tu n'as aucun goût
mais en plus tu es complètement folle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
catastrophe ou les joues
[Musique]
e
oh
vous n'avez pas vu mon collier tu me
trouves plus tôt collier je l'avais
posés sur la table de la cuisine
enfin il me semble moi je n'ai rien vu
[Musique]
je la trouve dans nos valeurs et le
collier naturellement puisque je suis un
croix détective ta personne ne bouge les
mains là
[Musique]
mais cloud ne casse rien compte ajoute
ne touche pas à ma boîte à poudre
on part vivre en poche je n'ai pas de
poche un temps tentée par un clou
exécutions pendant que dans tout simple
jeu nos pistes le grand détective est un
petit ventre comme la semaine de mal à
attaquer jusqu'au bout mais qui vous en
empêche monsieur le détective
je crois à sentir une odeur bizarre mon
gâteau il était en train de brûler si on
en mangeait cela nous remontrer un peu
le moral
anissa mêlera pense à ce que sap
enceinte et éthiques
qu'est-ce qui nous pouvons avoir toutes
qui n'a pas caché qu'un collier pourtant
faire offrir un deuxième aux coutumes y
chante pas de l'udc
si je n'avais pas assez de chagrin je te
demande pardon
tiens je te laisse la plus grosse part
du gâteau
une et par beaumont graco roubles au
courrier laval était tombé dans ma part
de loin
je suis vraiment un grand des petits
mots combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait
deux pattes opus nouveau trompé pas
voter bien sûr vaudois was a pas grand
chose attention il en manque un
[Musique]